the second time i met o.j simpson
[Applause]
was right after the trial of the century
there i was now a young man of probably
23.
o.j simpson was the most famous or
infamous face on planet earth
i was in a restaurant in beverly hills
with my agents i wasn't alone in the
restaurant but i was alone i was the
only black person in the restaurant
and in the 90s that felt very
uncomfortable
now i tend to enjoy it at this age
i was having dinner with my asians
celebrating a deal that they told me was
lucrative but i later learned [ __ ]
sucked
and suddenly
a group of women walked by
every race was in that group
black white
asian latina
white
white
and white again
they were all gorgeous i watched them
walk by
then
i saw a familiar face
al collins couldn't believe what i saw
and then close behind him
was o.j simpson newly released from jail
the restaurant fell still
i was shocked i didn't mean to say it
out loud but it just came out
oj
he stopped
turn around and see who said it saw my
black face and correctly assumed it was
me
[Applause]
i was sitting in the corner of the booth
he leaned over all the white people i
was having dinner with and shook my hand
how are you young man
he looked in my eyes and i could see in
his eyes that he didn't remember meeting
me the first time
and then he walked away
and i looked back at my agents
and all of them had nothing
short of disgust
on their faces
and the only one with the courage to
voice their disgust was a woman named
sharon who used to represent me
how could you she said
how could you shake hands
with that murderer
is a chairman with all due respect
that murderer ran for over 11 000 yards
[Applause]
now i could be bitter and blame all the
police but now
i'll tell you who i blame
it's those [ __ ] sketch artists
they keep drawing the same brother over
and over again
who is this generic man we all look like
i want to know what they say when it's
us
you know they only be in that room like
did you get a look
do you see the guy that tried to rob you
yes
yes i
did
he's about six feet tall i'd say six
feet tall yes
he had his head on backwards too good
that's good stuff hat
was on backwards yes
he was black okay big lips big nose dick
hanging out say no more sir
i'll draw them from memory
you know let me get my stencil i think
we can trace this guy and save some time
the only thing in our society that
bothers me the most is the way that men
and women don't get along no more
that's really what's bugging me about it
men and women just don't get along like
i hear women say this all the time i
know a lot of you says to be like
chivalry is dead don't you don't y'all
feel that way like men aren't gentlemen
anymore
that's right
chivalry is dead and women killed it
[Applause]
it's a fundamental difference in the way
we're going to see things we're not
going to see out on this issue
we're just not
our tests in life are different a
woman's test in life is material
a man's test in life
is a woman
now by test i mean that those are the
things that we desire men have nice cars
not because they like nice cars because
they know women like nice cars
that's how it goes
because men
are hunters
and the cars debate
and the woman comes and says nice
porsche gotcha [ __ ]
that's how it is
that's true
come on now you go to a woman's house
their house be comfortable as [ __ ] women
love comfortable surroundings so they
can get comfortable some rounds let me
tell you something if a man could [ __ ] a
woman in a cardboard box he wouldn't buy
a house
but that's still not where chivalry got
killed chivalry got killed by the
feminist movement on the magazines that
got women going crazy because women got
too much advice about men from other
women
and they don't know what the [ __ ] they
talking about
[Applause]
and it's true
i see this [ __ ] in the in the magazines
i don't read them but i'll be seeing the
cover i look at everybody in the grocery
store fellas he looked one of the
magazines like what is this and it's
going to cover 100 ways to please your
man by some lady
get out of here
ain't no hundred ways that this is four
things long just suckers dick play with
his balls and then fix them a sandwich
and don't talk so much
and then the magazines trick the women
the magazines start picking at your
self-esteem every page you turn you
start feeling fatter and uglier and you
feel like your clothes aren't good
enough and the magazines have you
forgetting how [ __ ] beautiful you are
and that's what happens now look what
happens
and then you forget how beautiful you
are we all suffer if [ __ ] was a stock
it would be plummeting right now because
you flooded the market with it you're
giving it away too easy
this is i'm just being truthful
[Applause]
i'm just talking
it would plummet
we'd be watching the news today [ __ ]
plumbing it
on
again
dynastar
gold is up 10 points
[Applause]
you can see it ever you ever have this
happen this is how confusing it is this
is the practical application what i'm
talking about like a guy be out it's
happening a lot of guys you'll be out of
club all right he's kicking with your
boys and a girl walks by and man she
looks good she looks good not good in
that classical way
i mean you know i'm talking good like
she got half her ass hanging out her
skirt
her titties are all mashed together
popping out the top of her turtleneck
and [ __ ]
[Applause]
and you with your buddies right you're
with your buddies you got a couple
drinks in here and your cigarettes you
might try to talk to this might not come
out right i don't know what you say damn
look at them titties
the girl can spanish
oh wait a minute wait a minute
just because i'm dressed this way
does not
[Music]
make me a [ __ ]
which is true
gentlemen that is true just because they
dress a certain way doesn't mean they
are a certain way don't ever forget it
but ladies you must understand that that
is [ __ ] confusing
just ends
now that would be like me dave chappelle
the comedian walking around the streets
in a cop uniform
somebody might run up on me oh thank god
officer help us come on they're over
here help us
oh
just because i'm dressed this way
does not make me a police officer
you understand what i'm saying
it's like all right lady fine
fine
you are not a [ __ ]
but you are wearing a horse uniform i'll
tell you that's right
your misunderstandings can happen
and then men we misunderstand women a
lot you know we we always undermine
their feelings you can't do that to them
you can't because
see feelings they see that clapping
feelings are very important to women
they are all important
i'm just learning this [ __ ]
everything's based on how they feel
you can hear when they tell stories you
ever told a man tell a story it'd be
just facts who what when where why it
was me and bob we use that safeway then
[ __ ] bob said this then i punched that
[ __ ] and i broke out
that's the story
that's the store
women tell stories all these feelings
well first of all you guys understand i
was on my period and i just talked to my
mother so i was feeling like they were
like ah damn too many feelings
what the [ __ ] happened to it
but i gotta talk about them
you gotta talk about them that's how
they always get me i'll be sitting there
watching tv chilling and [ __ ]
my old lady come up to me
david
we need to talk
[ __ ]
i don't say that out loud
that's how i feel inside
[Applause]
because i know every time we need to
talk
we need to talk about some [ __ ] that i
got to do
we don't even have to talk about
anything she needs to do
[Applause]
she leaves me defenseless
i have to do what i have to do
david
we need to talk
nah
don't do that to me david this is
serious stop talking in that voice now
see
i gotta do this thing
you're god damn sick of it this is the
worst time ever to be a celebrity you're
gonna be finished everyone's doomed
michael jackson has been dead for 10
years and this [ __ ] has two new cases
[Applause]
and if you haven't watched that
documentary uh then i'm begging you
don't watch it
it's [ __ ] gross
i felt like hbo was sticking baby dicks
in my ears for four hours straight
really nasty [ __ ]
i want to know all these things
turns out uh michael jackson allegedly
likes a long gander at the anus
so they said he stays in people's butt
holes that's what they said that's how
gross the documentary was
i'm going to say something that i'm not
allowed to say
but i gotta be real
i don't believe these [ __ ]
i do not
believe it
but
let me qualify the statement i i am
what's known on the streets as a victim
blamer
[Music]
you know what i mean somebody come up to
me like dave dave chris brown just beat
up rihanna i'll be like well what did
she do
[Applause]
dave michael jackson was molested
children well what were those kids
wearing at the time
[Applause]
i don't think he did it
well you know what
even if he did do it
you know what i mean
you know what i mean
i mean it's michael jackson
i know more than half the people in this
room have been molested in their lives
but it was no goddamn michael jackson
was it
this kid got his dick sucked by the king
of pop
all we get is awkward thanksgivings for
the rest of our lives
you know how good it must have felt to
go to school the next day after that
[ __ ]
hey billy how was the weekend how was my
weekend
michael jackson sucks my dick
[Applause]
and that was my first sexual experience
if i'm starting here then sky's the
limit
[Applause]
i know it seems harsh but man somebody's
got to teach these kids
there's no such thing as a free trip to
hawaii
he's going to want to look at your
butthole or something
[Applause]
you know why i don't believe it you know
i don't believe it because michael
jackson's out here doing all this
molesting that then why not mccully
hawking
mccauley calkin said in an interview
that michael jackson never did anything
inappropriate with him or even around
him think about that
[ __ ] you know
i'm not a pedophile
but if i was
mcculloch caulking is the first kid i'm
[ __ ] i'll tell you that right now
[Applause]
i'd be a goddamn hero hey that guy over
there [ __ ] the kid from home alone and
you know how hard he is to catch
[Applause]
all our stars man
our kelly pissed on his victim
i know it was rough
but i mean again i can't even judge r
kelly first of all we don't know if
these allegations are true and that even
if they are true if you want to know how
i feel about it honestly
if a man cannot pee on his fans
i don't want to be in show business
anymore because well that's why i got in
the game baby i got dreams too
you guys are confusing the issue while
you guys are busy worrying about if r
kelly even peed on this girl or not
you're not asking yourself the real
question that america needs to decide
once and for all and that question is
how old is 15 really
no that's a good question that's a good
question
i'm not saying that a person is as smart
as they're going to be at 15. that's not
what i'm saying man but i am saying
15 to me
is old enough to decide
whether or not you want to be pissed on
i mean that's me
if you can't make a decision like that
by the time you're 15 and just give up
[ __ ] because life is way harder
than that
i make tougher decisions all the time if
you don't want to get pissed on just get
the [ __ ] out of the way it's not even a
decision if i stop peeing on the front
row they're not gonna have to calculate
and think how do i feel about this am i
okay with it they just move
you can do that at 15. i could have i've
been 15. when i was 15
i was doing stand-up and nightclubs i
smoked reefer from time to time friends
were selling crack i was trying to
finger [ __ ] people i knew what was
happening around me
to some degree
getting pissed on was the least of my
worries at 15. trust me
but it keeps coming up it's a lot of
confusion around that age any time 15
comes up people freak out like when that
girl elizabeth smart got kidnapped
right remember you told last year's
15-year-old girl elizabeth smart was
kidnapped and then they finally found
her and the whole country was relieved
and i was the only one saying damn she
wasn't that smart after all
not cause she got kidnapped that could
happen to anybody i'm not knocking her
for that i'm just saying if you're
kidding at me when i was 15
you gotta take me further than eight
miles away from my house man god damn
can't hold me prison around [ __ ] i
recognize i'll break away i'll break
away [ __ ] off me [ __ ] that's my bus
stop i know where i'm at i'm going home
she was missing for six months eight
miles away from my house that's two
exits man that's nothing
and while she was missing during this
half a year that this girl was missing
there's a seven-year-old black girl gets
kidnapped in philadelphia
nobody knows her name they might talk
about it two or three times on the news
but she should have been top story
because she chewed through the ropes and
had both of these [ __ ] in jail
and 45 minutes flat 7 years old
i'm not making this up
these two crackheads kidnapped and took
her back to the crack house and tied her
up
and then they left her the crackheads
they got to make moves crack smoke
chocolate to eat these [ __ ]
made moves it was out
but as soon as they left this little
girl got the nibbling
she was kidnapped at four o'clock and at
home watching herself on the news at 5
30. that [ __ ] is crazy
that's a that's a news story
that is a news story
now
meanwhile in utah
15 year old elizabeth smart's captains
left her alone too and they didn't even
tie her up because they're hillbillies
they just bounced don't try to escape
[ __ ] or we'll kill you be right back
at least
she's 15 sitting in the house by herself
how am i gonna get out of this
come on
think
elizabeth
how am i gonna get out of here
why don't you just open the [ __ ] door
and go outside have you thought about
that
do you have a quarter do you know your
phone number your 15 [ __ ] run stop
thinking and stop making
moves i know i sound mean and i know
what the people are thinking when i'm
saying this dave she is only 15.
all right but that's the discrepancy
because when you talk about a little
girl like elizabeth smart then the
country feels like 15 is so young and so
innocent on the flip side here comes 15
again now we talking about a 15 year old
black kid in florida this black kid
accidentally killed his neighbor when
he's practicing wrestling moves that he
saw on tv now was he a kid no
they gave him life they always tried our
15 year olds as adults the snicker
nobody was doing
it's a goddamn pile driver
this kid gets on the ropes there's no
stopping him
you'd have to send the rock to arrest
them
and they gave a 15-year-old boy
life in jail
if you think that it's okay to give him
life in jail then it should be legal to
pee on them that's all i'm saying you
got to make up your mind across the
board how old 15 actually is that's all
i'm saying
so i'm gonna tell you right now if
somebody comes in here and puts a gun in
my head and says chappelle you got a
choice to make
you're either going to jail for a month
or we'll let you go
but you got to let our kelly pee on you
i'm not hesitating
bring in our kelly and tell him to stay
away from my eyes
i'd rather get pissed on the outside and
[ __ ] the butt on the inside son
i can't go to jail with some smooth
botox balls and think everything's going
to be all right it's not that kind of
place
take my chance with that pissed pistol
wash off with a 10 minute shower i'm
certain of it
coming right out
what can i do they're going to put me in
it's jail much pressure
that's my problem i can't i can't handle
pressure
sometimes pressure makes me talk
different i'm serious you ever have like
that social pressure talk to somebody
who's fake and they make you fake
like that comedy like hey how you doing
you're like fine are you like
i don't even talk like that
[Applause]
i get sick of that [ __ ]
i do it makes me sick sometimes i'll
talk crazy just to make myself feel
better he'll do that and start talking
like crazy have you ever heard his voice
man
that's how bad guys used to talk in the
40s
in the old days say i talk like that not
all the time but if somebody put the
pressure on me [ __ ] it i gotta i gotta
cut loose
the police pull me over i'll talk crazy
son son
do you know why we pulled you over
nah cause i'm black see that's right
don't do it
it's not illegal to talk like that
how do they know i don't talk like that
every day stop talking like that stop
talking about wild copper
sorry talk see
you got to make life interesting like
that because the [ __ ] is flimsy
life is flimsy you think you're gonna
live for anybody not gonna live forever
it's dangerous out here we know what's
going on
i travel now you know i just think dc
had the roughest ghettos in the country
no [ __ ]
i have seen some [ __ ] now
oh there's some rough rough areas
outside of dc
yeah everybody should go to the ghetto i
was taking it together one time that's
the worst when you get taken you're not
expecting to go
you know usually you want to know when
you're going to get it like i'm going to
see some wild [ __ ] i got to prepare
myself i'm going to do something crazy
when you're taking it's different
i had a limousine driver
it was after shows late at night it's
like three in the morning
had limousine drive he's a nice guy
talking to me and [ __ ] oh hey where you
from dawg
dc word
[Applause]
that's a rough city man
and the cell phone started ringing hold
on one second
hello
oh what's up [ __ ] what
what the [ __ ] slow that what what the
[ __ ]
no
no
no [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm on my way
hey
i gotta make a stop real quick
at three o'clock in the morning i didn't
know he was taking me to the ghetto at
first i started looking out the window i
was like what the [ __ ] gun store gun
store liquor store store where the [ __ ]
you taking me
this don't look good
he didn't say [ __ ]
just pulled up in front of an old
rickety building
that looked like a project now i've
never been there before i'm not sure if
it was a project but
it certainly had all the familial
symptoms of a project
a [ __ ] crackhead ran this way
and then another one jumped out a tree
and [ __ ]
and i said i'll be right back
and left me took the keys with me just
let me
at three o'clock in the morning in front
of a project in a [ __ ] limousine
this was not good
i was like man i gotta look around see
if i can see some landmarks and
figure out where i'm at
might have to escape on foot
that is when i know i was in a bad
neighborhood you only see this in the
worst neighborhoods remember it's three
o'clock in the morning it's three
o'clock in the morning
i look out the window
it was a [ __ ] baby standing on a
corner
[Applause]
and the baby the baby didn't even look
scared he was just standing there
i mean it made me sad it made me feel
really good because i want to help the
baby
i don't trust you either i'm sorry click
the old baby on the corner trick eh
you're not going to fall for that [ __ ]
where's this limousine driver you know i
stopped feeling bad
as time goes by i start feeling worse
like man what is wrong with me what the
hell is wrong i'm scared of a baby
and this baby could be in trouble he
might need my help
i got to do something
but i wasn't going to get out the car
i'm serious man i just cracked the
window a little bit
there's an old limousine i can roll it
down
[Applause]
hey baby
baby go home man it's 3 o'clock in the
morning what the [ __ ] are you doing
now the baby's saying i'm selling weed
[ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm sorry i had to buy two bags from the
coal miners i'll get two when i get too
funny
[Applause]
got back in the car and rolled me a
joint man
that [ __ ] was scary man every once in a
while like a crack kid would come up to
the car and look in the window it was
like jurassic park and should he be
looking at all the cars
hey get out of here cracky
that baby was still standing there man
that's not feeling bad again yeah we
make you feel guilty sometimes
man what is wrong with me man i have
just brought weed from from an infant
i can't condone this kind of behavior
what am i thinking i can't let the fear
ruin my morals
got to do something
hey baby
stop selling wheat all right you got
your whole life ahead of you
he said [ __ ] you [ __ ] i got kids to
feed that's a guy
[Applause]
can't do everything
maybe weed
we're going to do something do a little
weed smokes we we use not as bad as
everything else
it's weed is a background substance
i mean you can smoke some herb and still
function
and you ain't crisp
but you'll function
nothing higher than weed though
i made that mistake one time
i was at a party some guy gave me some
[ __ ] he's like here man take this it's
[ __ ] mushrooms
i took it i forgot all about it you know
then a couple days later i found that
[ __ ] in my pocket i'm thinking why not
cause i'm thinking it's like weed some
background [ __ ]
i planned my whole day out like it was
weed
i'll chew this [ __ ] up
then i'll go to the barber shop get my
hair cut and then i'll see a movie
i chewed it up
so far so good
then i was in a barber shop
like an hour later
and it's funny because i was just
thinking to myself
this stuff sucks
tastes like athlete's foot
i feel sick but i'm not really high
then i looked in the mirror
i saw the barber's reflection man
it looked like
it looked like a big penis was cutting
my hair
i freaked out
i started talking to myself dave calm
down
you're on drugs
this is what drugs do
okay you know
that there is no way
that a penis
can cut hay
but i started freaking out man i just
couldn't take it anymore i jumped out
the chair half my hair was cut i didn't
care
i didn't i just gave a bob a handful of
money
it was weird the balls opened up anyway
i
i ran home man i banned home as fast as
i could
it's tripping
i looked at the clock it was 2 42 i was
like damn 2 42.
i got a sober up
i never been this high this early
i took a shower
i was still high
i said maybe music will do the trick
i listened to every cd i had
i was still high
exercise that's what i'll do i ran
around the block four times still high
took a nap woke up [ __ ] up
i looked at the clock it was 243 i said
god
but there's a more important reason that
i would stop doing comedy right now
and this reason is the real reason
that's been percolating and it really is
the crowd not you
i'm talking about
the crowd on the big stage it's too hard
to entertain a country whose ears are so
brittle
[ __ ] are so sensitive the whole
country is turned into bitch-ass [ __ ]
everything you say upsets somebody
but [ __ ] are just taking it too
far i don't know why or how everybody
got this goddamn sensitive you know who
hates me the most the transgender
community
yo yeah these [ __ ] i mean i
didn't realize how bad it was these
[ __ ] i was really mad about
that last netflix special
it's tough man i don't know what to do
about it because
because i like them
i always have never had a problem with
them
you know
just [ __ ] around
and matter of fact i think i make fun of
everybody and
i mean as a group of people they have to
admit
kind of [ __ ] hilarious man i'm sorry
bro it's like
i've never seen somebody in such a
hilarious predicament
not have a sense of humor about it
they're born feeling like there's
something other than they're born as and
that's
that's kind of funny you know
it's funny if it's not happening to you
i believe transgenders i don't
understand them either but i know
they mean what they say
then they just cut their dicks off
that's all the proof i need
i've never seen somebody just throw
their dick away don't need it
[Applause]
i don't understand but i believe you and
i support your decision [ __ ]
[Applause]
there's a problem in that feminist
movement isn't there
from its inception in america
there's always been a racial component
when susan b anthony was having that
meeting and sojourner troops black ass
showed up
read your history books all the white
women asked sojourner truth not to speak
they didn't want to conflate the issues
of women's rights and slavery
but you know how black [ __ ] are so
truth went up there anyway
[Applause]
she did a famous speech she said ain't i
a woman
ain't i a woman
that's right and listen listen listen i
i supported the me too movement but but
the whole time
the whole time i thought that the way
they handled that was stupid
it was it was white it was like
[Music]
they were doing [ __ ] like going to the
golden globes and all of them would be
like let's all go to the golden globes
and wear black dresses to give these men
a piece of our minds [ __ ] that is not
gonna work
you think martin luther king's gonna be
like i want everybody to keep riding the
bus but we're matching outfits
you gotta get off the bus and walk
it's real talk a real talk that was a
silly movement
i want everybody to wear a crochet [ __ ]
hat so they know we're serious
what the [ __ ] was he all doing
and then i said something about it in
one of my specials and all these women
actresses came after me i said man [ __ ]
y'all too you canceled i ain't jerking
off the none of your pictures again
they were like who is he to tell us
anything i'll tell you exactly who i am
i'm the one that got off the bus and
left 50 million dollars on the bus and
walked
i agreed with these women i just didn't
agree with what they were
doing about
right
right no it was annoying as [ __ ]
because if these women were serious you
know what they would have done
they all would have fired their agents
and they would have went to the mailroom
of one of these big agencies and found a
woman that was busting her up in there
and said if you want to talk to us
then you have to talk to her
and if they did that
then she would be big and they would be
big and nobody would get fed to harvey
weinstein but did they do that
no
was that their idea
no
surprisingly it was mine
when i think the feminist movement needs
to be very successful
as a male leader
[Applause]
i'll do it
i will i will lead you women to the
promised land
i will make sure you get equal pay it
will work
i will make sure that nobody harasses
you or [ __ ] with you on the job i will
protect all of your interests and all
that i ask for in return
was that you suck my dick
and now we're right back to square one
aren't we
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
timmy was one of my first
white friends like in my life man
good dude too he moved to silver spring
from utah of all places
i guess his family was affiliated with
that mormon church they got down there
and me and him used to hang out and one
day i was at his house we were just
hanging out and timmy says dave
why don't you stay for dinner tonight
i said oh man i'd love to but i can't
if i'm not home before dark my mother
will kill me
that was a lot
my mother had several jobs i hadn't seen
her like three or four days
and the only reason i lied to timmy was
because at that point in my life it was
my experience
that white dinner wasn't delicious
[Applause]
i'd rather go home and fry some bologna
or some [ __ ] like that
[Applause]
but then old timmy threw me a curve ball
i wasn't expecting he said oh it's too
bad you can't stay dave cause um
[Music]
mom made stovetop stuffing
i said what the [ __ ] stovetop
hold on [ __ ] let me make some phone
calls real quick
i had seen that commercial so many times
i had dreamt of getting my hands on some
of that stovetop stuffing
and finally i met a [ __ ] that
actually had a box of stovetop in the
house i couldn't miss this opportunity
so i pretended to call my mother
and then i came back and i said timmy
timmy you're not gonna believe this
great news mom said i can stay and he
said fantastic he said why don't you
come with me and we'll help set the
table and then we can say the blessing i
had no
interest in setting this motherfucker's
table of saying these crazy-ass mormon
prayers
i just wanted that god damn stuffing
so i told him i said you know what i'd
love to help but let me go wash my hands
first my plan was simple
wash my hands slowly and by the time i'm
done the table will be set the blessing
will be said and all that there will be
left to do
is eat
i went to the bathroom
i washed my hands very slowly i must
have been in there for about 10 minutes
and suddenly
one of his mothers came to the door
[Applause]
[Music]
she was like hi
david right
i said yes ma'am
she said timmy tells me that you're
planning on staying for dinner i said i
hope that's not a problem ma'am
she says no it's no problem in fact we'd
love to have you it's just that we
weren't expecting company and i'm afraid
there's not enough stove top stuffing
for everybody
so i kicked her in the [ __ ]
bam
ladies and gentlemen
i told you i'm dope [ __ ]
i told you i was gonna say and you still
didn't see it coming
and that's why i make the big bucks
[Applause]
you know i feel real bad for us is
indians
everybody feels bad for indians they get
dog they get dogged openly because
everybody thinks they're dead
these [ __ ] are not all dead all
right i've seen with my own eyes i've
seen a gathering of 1500
native americans they were all gathered
in one place the place is called um
walmart in new mexico
there's indians ever i've never seen
indians before i wasn't even sure if
they were indians i was [ __ ] up but i
asked one of them
it's not nice but i seen him in the
sports section
looking at bows and arrows i had to say
something excuse me
[Applause]
cause i i don't mean to be rude
um
are you an indian
and he was cool yes
yes i'm indian
still didn't believe him
i had to test him to be sure this was
[ __ ] up but i had a gum wrapper in my
pocket so i bawled that [ __ ] up and i
threw it on the floor
and a single tear came out his eye said
oh [ __ ]
i had so many questions
what trap are you from
i am
a navajo
i said word
i studied you in social studies
you're a hunter gatherer correct
is that i guess so
that's what you wish to call it
i said wow what do you call it he said i
am
an alcoholic
[Applause]
i said well what's your name dog he said
please
dog is my cousin that's a good guess my
name is
running coyote
what is your name friend
and that [ __ ] caught me off guard i mean
i didn't want to say my name was dave
to a [ __ ] name running coyote
just don't feel good enough he's putting
me on the spot
i said huh my name what
oh my name's uh blackfeet
then i change the subject forget about
me what's going on with you
i want to meet your chief
why don't me you and your chief and your
friends get together tonight we can have
a real live peace pipe smoking ritual we
need to celebrate [ __ ] i thought you
were dead
and he set it up it was beautiful it was
just like our dream was all sitting
around indians was beating the drum
[Music]
some other indians came out the back
with a long blanket that was folded in
half and put in in front of us
open that [ __ ] up and on the blanket was
a long wooden pipe with feathers
and bags of weed were all over the
blanket
chief walked over
the big ones are 50. the little ones are
25
and these are 10.
man those indians got high as [ __ ]
i was big i told her she was talking i
cut him off timeout chief
sorry to interrupt
[ __ ] smash man the weeds too strong
i'm itching this is pcp the spirits have
got me chief the spirits have got me
and the chief threw some water in my
face calm down blackface splash
i said hey it's black feet [ __ ]
take it easy
blackfeet
you're welcome to stay amongst me and my
tribe for the night
until the spirits leave you
and they gave me my own teepee to sleep
in
which sounds nice i personally felt like
it was a little [ __ ] up
you know because they all had houses man
it's like why can't i sleep with y'all
in the house and watch tv the guy can't
be on his grass all night
now i was hanging out with a friend of
mine he's a white guy you know we were
just hanging out here and we were lost
in the city you know we're smoking a
joint now i don't know if it's a
coincidence that we were lost and hiding
[ __ ] but
my white buddy he was smoking a joint
dave dave
it's the goddamn cops
[Applause]
i'm gonna ask him for directions
i said chip no
chip don't do it
it was too late
he was walking over there this man was
high as [ __ ] excuse me
excuse me sir touching him and [ __ ]
excuse me
[Applause]
you need some information
oh
stop confessing things you shouldn't
confess i'm a little high
all i want to know
which way is third street the cop was
like hey take it easy
you're on third street
you better be careful
go ahead move it
move it
that's all that happened at the end of
the story
now
i know that's not amazing to some of you
but yes one of these black fellas that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] incredible isn't it
i'm saying a black man would never dream
of talking to the police high
that's a waste of weed
serious
i mean i'll be scared to talk to the
police when i'm sleepy
they [ __ ] around get the wrong ideas
oh
oh my god
that [ __ ] was on pcp johnson
i had to use necessary force
you saw him
no no no paperwork just just sprinkle
some crack on them let's get out of here
that's how it is but at the time i
didn't think it was anything racial
about it i was just like man chip you
got [ __ ] luck you better be careful
but then another time me and chip are
driving
now i'm not driving
chip is driving and he's driving a
little crazy he's been drinking
i don't like to let my friends drive
drunk but you know
i was smoking a joint i couldn't really
say [ __ ] to the guy
[Applause]
and we get a red light we stop at a red
light and a car pulls up next to us and
i'll never forget it chip he looks at me
he's all drunk and she's like
dave
i'm gonna race him
[Applause]
i knew it was a bad idea
but i was high
i tried to explain though it was a bad
idea but all that came out
well [ __ ] sometimes you got race i
don't know
man
that light turned green and chip took
off
zig zagging and ships and oils are
passing out i didn't know he was racing
then the police seen us and pulled us
over they understand i'm scared of [ __ ]
i mean come on the car smells like weed
i mean speeding this man is [ __ ]
drunk
i was scared
chip was not scared at all it was weird
he didn't turn his radio down and it was
weird a little bit
i mean if you get pulled over once you
turn your radio down
nobody won't get their ass beat to a
soundtrack and [ __ ]
i'm
saying
chip had the music blasting we're not
gonna take it
whatever is it dave just relax close
your butt cheeks just relax
[Applause]
let me do the talking
you want to know what he said
is almost exactly what he said i
couldn't believe it he says oh oh
sorry officer i
i didn't know i couldn't do that
i was [ __ ] shocked
the cops said well now you know
get out of here just get the [ __ ] out of
here
[Applause]
she said okay oh i will sir thank you
what
what's wrong with you dave
i didn't know i couldn't do that
he said that was good wasn't it
because i did know i couldn't do that
i'll be real with you and i know nobody
gives a [ __ ] what i think anyway uh
i'm not for abortion
oh shut up [ __ ]
[Applause]
i'm not for it but i'm not against it
either
it all depends
on who i get pregnant
i don't care i'll tell you right now i
don't care what your religious beliefs
are anything if you have a dick you need
to shut the [ __ ] up on this one
seriously
[Applause]
this is theirs
the right to choose is their unequivocal
rights not only do i believe they have
the right to choose i believe that they
shouldn't have to consult anybody
except for a physician
about how they exercise that right
gentlemen that is fair
and ladies to be fair to us
i also believe if you decide to have the
baby
a man should not have to pay
[Applause]
that's fair
if you can kill this [ __ ] i can
at least abandon them
it's my money my choice
[Applause]
and if i'm wrong then perhaps we're
wrong
figure that [ __ ] out for yourselves
[Applause]
i mean really uh what the [ __ ] are we
doing
i can't live in this new world you're
proposing and meanwhile while we're
worrying about all this other [ __ ] look
at what's happening they just killed
another 12 people in a mass shooting in
virginia beach this is happening every
week it happens so much i'm almost i
don't care anymore
i came home early from the road
i had a twelve thousand dollar suit on
because life's been going good
and i got home early and dinner was
cooking you ever come home and dennis
cooking then that smell good
and my son saw me and he was like dad's
home and he got up from the table and
ran over to give me a hug but he had
chicken grease all over his face so i
stepped on him like yo yo yo yo my man
watch these threads son it's an
expensive suit i don't want to get the
chicken grease all over me
and he was like what the chicken grease
damn this is duck
tear came out of my eyes
i never dreamt i'd do so well in life
that i'd raised a [ __ ] with duck grease
all over his face
this one time racism saved my life man i
was i was on a plane
i was coming i was coming from overseas
and i don't know how this guy got a
machine gun on the plane but he stood up
man he said everybody get on the [ __ ]
ground
nobody look at my face
i started freaking out
because he was chinese i was like why is
he talking like that
he was screaming and crying
i was the only brother on the plane well
i thought his only brother i looked over
there was one of the black dude he's
from nigeria i i looked over there he
was looking right in my face man he
didn't say two words to me he just
looked at me he was like
he didn't need to talk i know just what
he's talking about look right back at
him i was like
[Applause]
some white dudes on the front of the
plane cena they were like oh my god
i think those black guys are going to
try to save us
[Applause]
we were just communicating that we
understood the situation
we were both seeing the same thing what
we understood was simple
terrorists don't take black hostages
that's the truth
i have yet to see one of us on the news
reading the hostage letters
um
they is treating us good
uh we all chilling and [ __ ]
i'd like to give a shout out to ray ray
and big steve and
jason
[Applause]
you're not gonna see it
and terrorists are smart they know what
they're doing there you know
they terrorists
they know black people's bad bargaining
chips
they call the white house hello
we have got five black hello
[Applause]
he'd be back in dc you know what i'm
just thinking man this is this is an
election year
i'm gonna ask you yo i got do you know
who you're voting for yet
don't know do you
now you see that
you see what just happened here let me
tell you something that is a cultural
thing
he knows who he's gonna vote for he's
just not gonna tell me
see
i've noticed that
that is a cultural thing
white people do not like to talk about
their political affiliations it's a
secret yeah that's why guy who's voting
for you hey bob uh bob who you gonna
vote for dave dave whoa
take it easy now
take it easy
so anyway um i was [ __ ] my wife in
her ass right
and i mean it was something else
yeah yeah yeah yeah but but who are you
voting for dave
babe come on with the voting i'm trying
to tell you about [ __ ] my wife here
asking me all these personal questions
they don't like to divulge that
information because it matters to them
black people talk about that [ __ ] black
people will openly talk about politics
but people openly talk about beating up
politicians and [ __ ]
i see george bush i'll kick his
[ __ ] ass for cutting my
medicaid
probably just say it
but there's a reason for that because it
matters more for that matters more black
people see see even when i vote right
which i don't but but
but even when i like think about like
who i would vote for
right
i don't even look at their political
policies i just look at their character
you know what i'm saying now you gotta
really know i'm serious you gotta read
between the lines
like you know you look at clinton and
black people like clinton because we've
seen him on the campaign i saw one thing
on the campaign trail he actually just
picked the black baby up and kicked him
come here little [ __ ] baby
[Music]
i like that
he did not hesitate or nothing
you see george bush
like say i'd never vote for george bush
jr but i don't know george was junior's
politics the only thing i know about
george bush jr is that that guy sniffed
cocaine that's right now listen we
cannot have that [ __ ] in the white house
that might be fine for a mayor but god
they may not know
[Applause]
the states are too high in the white
house you can't have no coke head
president
he'd be selling nuclear seekers for
twenty thirty dollars and [ __ ]
could be in meetings embarrassing
america
come on
sign the treaty baby
i suck your dick like what the [ __ ]
[Applause]